hello and welcome to this video playing
Vesuvio RT car something like that
problem in playing a Sicilian that see
what happens here we've got them in a
Lapine c3 soil
Bishop e3 your God do you go what do you
do him and I'd have six or is that c4
okay yeah I think it's it's right yeah
it's a correct move and now will you
take
hmm okay I'm not really knowledgeable
him how do we play this stuff I wonder
if he six is good or he five e five
looks ambitious Bishop c4 I can probably
take on G to them so when he plays it
quite quickly so it might be that this
is actually a known theoretical position
this is an ambitious try let's try that
I can just get this is fantastic the
problem could be you know there's Queen
eighty four stuff or maybe Bishop c4 but
Bishop c4 I think I can take III okay as
is entirely entirely harmless so what do
we do what do we do Knight e3 or minute
and want to trade the Queen yeah that's
so let's do it
okay so take this one yeah that's true
yeah I'm not going to give you the
bishop pair back I could forget about
that
I know the king is a little bit silly
only seven but yeah it's just nothing I
could do about it it's just what it is
for the moment so how do we do this a g6
Bishop GP should age 6 or I would like
to have it on c5 when I don't really
have a great I should have gone to d8
actually with the king and then to c7 it
would have been better anyway taking too
long
yeah why what noises it's really a bit
of a problem it's nowhere to go hmm let
us again not right I should really know
anyway I have to be somewhat quicker but
and they need Bishop f8 the Bishop one
age six I just put it there to make the
rooks to connect the rook cell and it's
not supposed to be there for the rest of
the game okay so he tries to play what
no yeah Bishop to b3 it would be me it's
a bit of an annoyance it should be 3 g8
it could be a problem so how do we do
this
the knight seafoam
Oh Kim
yeah they're my pieces so it's good to
have bishops but they need some sort of
coordination and when it's not ideal to
say the least
it's not ideal
really really
k2g seven huh no okay
it makes the conversion even a bit
easier because you get to trade this
no probably it's best to attack the
pawns from behind let's put them on
ducks Chris I know this one he always
has to watch over those pawns and I can
now going over do I have something
simple I don't I don't think so
I'm just wondering no it should be it
should be correct
put this here starting with this is
probably best can also just block it
every Spirit that's easiest actually
let's block the pawn
yeah that's the easiest I could have
also gone over to the to the other side
of the board but you can simply let him
run out of moves
Oh completely forgot that he can go
there it doesn't doesn't matter all that
much
let's so forgot that this is possible
okay so I made a couple of bad decisions
in the opening I'm fairly certain okay
yes he takes night text what I know is
that this is not good because you take
on only three Bishop takes pawn takes
Queen takes long and then black is
clearly better that's the line that I
know he just took them okay take take
and the engine yeah me five seems to be
okay it's no immediate punishment
available ninety-four
yeah Queen f3 that that cannot be
critical but I'm not sure what critical
move the risk will be three it seems
yeah but I'm still okay down yeah no no
I'm just going to be better that the
question is I think I made a couple of
mistakes here I took and he gave this
cheque and queen king is seven is really
terrible if you think about it just for
with a clear head like this one he has
to take and f6
the game but I get here and this is a
lot better and then we have an easy
development here or here it's it's
that's a lot better in comparison black
a slightly better as the engine suggests
because of the the pay of the ships but
this is not super relevant at the moment
because he's gotten also some chances
based on the better development
Damon's got this was check yeah this one
and yeah I don't think why this in any
severe trouble yeah and now it's it's a
little bit yeah kingi - I don't know
lucky ones maybe better I'm a little bit
uncoordinated so oe4 why is it great
official Jafar oh yeah think about
tactics not just strategic stuff that's
often issue in my game you know I have
this you know I have this position of
narrative like you can't be sure pay I
need to coordinate and so on and I don't
think about concreteness
that just finished the exchange for
absolutely nothing
now this should cheer for next okay yeah
weekend before I simply didn't think
about it
and now he's got yet he would have
played people to play this would have
been a bit better even know I mean I'm I
have I'm the one to play because of my
bishops but it's his PC is very active
and it's I think it's equal ish so here
doing all the normal moves that same I
was intended to play at 5m possible and
tiene back here because of Bishop g8
which he played and now we played the
move Bishop H sandwiches of course it's
just blundering its traps the bishop
yeah I was expecting yeah something like
if wines we have my pieces are just not
bad not well played so it's probably
nothing much equal and after that I'm
winning the piece you know maybe maybe
actually here efore is better
may it's a bit simpler I mean this wins
but it is still a bit of a bit of plane
so b5 this I was a little bit of back
and forth because I reconsidered the way
to plane here I thought it's easiest
simply stop the pawn entirely no he's
just getting pushed back and in the
scenario you just have to Bishop a5 was
better doing be a museum push me Bishop
a5 was a lot simpler when then we nice
of course but the other month was easy
and now at the end I'm winning efore and
and with it the game yeah ok guys thanks
for watching